the film and the franchise is so popular
so unbelievably successful do you feel
like there's a huge amount of scrutiny
pressure you're a victim of your own
success in some ways Naomi um I don't I
really feel that way this time because
um I felt a lot of pressure before the
movie was kind of seen by people but now
it's out there and you know lots of
reviewers have seen it and absolutely
loved it the response we've been having
has been incredible we've got five star
reviews so now we just feel like we're
in a fantastic position and our main aim
is really just to enjoy it yeah do you
feel like you can enjoy it now man yeah
well neither of us have seen it seen the
film so we wait a lot of mundane really
excited to go on mundanes and actually
see it then yeah well I won't ruin it
for you but one of the plot lines is
surveillance and do you think that we're
over monitored here in this country
because that's one of the big talking
points mm-hmm I don't know it's um it's
a complicated issue I think and I think
it's definitely worrying i'm not i'm not
going to get to the bottom of it in this
interview probably but yeah it's
something is frightening certainly by
the way of heading yeah in one way it's
great because we're protected you know
when people go missing or you know what
have you can track their whereabouts and
and that's really fantastic it's just
that if it gets into the wrong hands
yeah exactly yeah the one of the
wonderful things about bond seems to be
that it's able to update its always kind
of moving forward and bond is definitely
less sexist than it used to be and it's
women are portrayed in a completely
different way do you feel like this
further to go or do you think you're
kind of there now I think we're in a
fantastic position now I really do I
felt I feel as though you know women are
really contributing to the plot they're
integral to the story and and I think
that's you know what women viewers want
as well you know and that's incredibly
important and it means that the story is
balanced as well now so I think we're in
a great place so is the next step a
female bonds or a black bond is that the
next stage
I don't think it's really about female
or black or you know any ethnicity or
what-have-you I think it's about the
essential qualities of whoever inhabits
bond and that's about magnetism skill in
the field and charisma and sexuality as
well you know all of this thing danger
yeah yeah yeah